في التطورات على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه اعلن حزب الله عن تنفيذه
عمليتين ضد مواقع اسرائيليه قباله الحدود
الجنوبيه للبنان وقال الحزب ان مقاتليه
استهدفوا مقر قياده اللواء الشرقي التابع
لفرقه الجليل في ثكنه كريات شموه كما هاجم
حزب الله بالصواريخ ثكنه برانيت
الاسرائيليه في الجليل الاعلى مؤكدا تحقيق
اصابه مباشره وافاد مراسل الجزيره باطلاق
صواريخ من جنوب لبنان باتجاه مستوطنه
الامط
في اصبع الجليل وباتجاه مواقع اسرائيليه
في مزارع شبعه المحتله وشنت المقاتلات
الاسرائيليه غارات على بلدتي الخيام واكفر
كلا في جنوب لبنان كما قصفت المدفعيه
بلدات العديسه وطير حرفا
والجبين معنا من مرجع عيون جنوبي لبنان
مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقده معك ايهاب
واخر التطورات على طول خط
الحدود
خلال الساعه الماضيه هدات الجبهه بعض
الشيء لكن الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
لازالت تحلق بشكل مكثف في اجواء جنوب
لبنان وربما هذا يدفع الى التخوف من ان
تشن هذه الطائرات غارات جديده بعد
استهدافات منها لثلاث بلدات لبنانيه في
مناطق مختلفه من جنوب لبنان ابرز هذه
الاستهدافات كان اليوم في بلده الخيام
التي تقع خلف في تماما غرات عليها من قبل
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ولم يفد عن
وقوع اصابات ايضا على مقربه من بلده
الخيام وتحديدا كفرك التي تبعد عنها
كيلومترات قليله اغارت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على هذه البلده ودمرت منزلا
ولم يفد عن وقوع اصابات وهاتين البلدتين
تقعان تماما قرب مستوطنه المطل
الاسرائيليه التي تعد احد النواحي القريبه
من كري شموه التي استهدفت هذا اليوم من
قبل حزب الله الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه كذلك اغارت على بلده طير حرفا
دون تسجيل اصابات من جانب حزب الله كان
هناك ايضا هجمات من او اطلاق صواريخ من
الجانب اللبناني
باتجاه عالي تلال كفر شوبه ومزارع شبعه
اعترضتها الدفاعات الجويه الاسرائيليه
التي اطلقت بكثافه باتجاه هذه الصواريخ
التي انطلقت من جنوب لبناني المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه شاركت بقصف محيط عدد من
البلدات وتحديدا البلدات التي تقع قرب
كفرشوبا رشيه الفخار وايضا اطراف الفرنس
والهب وكذلك كفركلا والخيام وايضا مناطق
اخرى وبلدات اخرى من جنوب لبنان تلك
القريبه من الاماكن التي وقعت فيها هجمات
حزب الله اعلن عن مهاجمه موقعين يتسمان
بانهما من اي مهمين وقياده عسكريه للجانب
الاسرائيلي ثكنه برانيت التي تضم الفرقه
قياده الفرقه ال91 استهدف حزب الله
بالصواريخ وقال في بيان انه حقق اصابات
ايضا فرقه او اللواء المشاه الذي يسيطر
على المنطقه الحدوديه في القطاع الشرقي
استهدفه حزب الله قرب كريات ش مونا
بالصواريخ وحقق اصابات وفقا للبيان الذي
اعلنه اثر هذا الاستهداف من القطاع الشرق
a